my thinking is that you guys remember if
you want to be successful learn from the
other people's mistakes don't learn from
the successful stories there are a lot
of reasons behind it I remember the
first time Harvard Business School came
to us say Jack we want to write a case
study for you they came to spend one
week and they write a report and I read
I said this is not me this is you I said
no this is not us the next five years
they invited me to go to the case study
you learn from mistakes not because you
will be able to avoid mistakes when
these mistakes come they suffer comes
you know how to deal with it the book I
want to write if I want is Alibaba 10001
mistake this is the most treasurable
thing in my life in my life it's not how
much we achieved it's how much we go
through the tough days and mistakes and
this is if you step to think now
need motivation watch your top 10 with
believe Nation what's up it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to say explode
out onto the world so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and show
in today's lessons from a man who went
from growing up in China and giving
tours to tourists for free for nine
years just to learn English to becoming
one of the wealthiest people in the
world with a net worth of over 50
billion dollars he's Jack Ma and here's
my take on his top 10 rules of success
volume three enjoy
[Music]
rule number two focus on quality not
size last century the bigger the better
this Century The Good the better do the
business not because the size it does
not necessarily the big size you are the
more profit you are you really believe
that I believe there's a difference you
know we've got a Fortune 500 companies
you you judge because of the size how
many of them are really happy how many
of them have a profit no small companies
they're very profitable they're very
happy they can spend time with the wife
and the husband and kids traveling
around and
that's the life rule number three be the
first don't try to be the best
be the first
be the first to change
be the first to chat take the challenge
be the first one to overcome the
difficulties
because the best person there's only one
Olympic champion
I don't think I'm lucky enough to be
that
but I can always try the new things and
don't give I believe it because you you
are so unique everybody is unique be
yourself is always the key rule number
four prepare for the future people like
me I was born in a very poor family I
never got a great education
and I failed all the examinations for
what reason I don't know
but later I realized I don't have money
I don't have technology I don't have a
lot of good backgrounds we have a rich
uncle or something no the only thing I
compete with my people the young people
is let's compete for 10 years later
this is what I believe 10 years later
will be happening so everything I do for
that girl I know
10 years later this thing is going to
happen so prepare for that
because I know if I compete with him for
next month no chance
so this is how my message is up it's a
challenge
but it's opportunity
and it's the opportunity for people like
us
this world the most difficult thing is
the convincing a successful people
ah wait tell him this is a great
opportunity he said forget it right I've
been doing this for 30 years
but for people like us
we're looking for opportunities in order
to survive
so we will do anything to be creative so
this is the message
30 years it's opportunity for us it's a
challenge for those people who are 60
years old
if they're 60 years old
I'm not not discrimination but it's not
it is tough for them also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five respect your
competitors who's your most dangerous
competitor is it Amazon or is it 10 cent
well people always think compare us with
Amazon is a great company I respect I've
been seeing them from Tiny to that big
and I think they will continue to grow
but we are different we the Amazon is an
e-commerce company we are not e-commerce
company
we enable other people to do e-commerce
we want to making sure everybody can be
Amazon
so are you saying tencent is the greater
uh oh they are gay
they're great only such less than 20
years so innovative
and so creative are so different on
social technology and their base things
in East engine and they're almost
everywhere in China my respect of course
we compete but computers not me I have
to hate them don't hate your competitors
respect your competitors learn from him
but you know Pony and I we've been doing
the charity together the nature
conservancy and protected the or but we
compete each other but when we compete
each other
we should respect each other I respect
him I respect tencent rule number six
see challenges as opportunities Miss
World today is a full of challenges and
opportunities two thousand years ago
full of challenges and opportunities and
I'm sure 2 000 years later full of
challenges and opportunities there is
always it depends on how you look at
somebody look at this challenge as
opportunity young people always say
there's no opportunity I complain a lot
when I was young because I think Bill
Gates took all the opportunities for the
Microsoft and Steve Jobs all these guys
there's no job up there's no great
big stuff left for us
but I think
opportunity always lies in the
challenges
always lies in the complaints
if you can solve the challenge you have
to you you will be successful the Big
Challenge yourself the big problem of
the the big opportunity you have rule
number seven my personal favorite
belief in the past 18 years when I do
internet in China we got a criticism
everything you know something where you
believe it a lot of people criticize it
but if you really believe continue to do
it improve it we were rejected by more
than 30 Venture capitalists but we are
very optimistic we believe in the future
we believe in Internet and we believe
that if we do not succeed somebody will
rule number eight surround yourself with
greatness how do I motivate uh
incentive by our colleagues
you have to find the people that can
mobilize themselves
it's impossible to find to to encourage
a negative person
so the people you hide the people work
together
they they have to be oh you cannot we
have a 65 000 in price now you cannot
hire all of them that positive but at
least the people work with me
my management leadership
several areas they have to be positive
they have to know the to incentive the
others because I cannot incent everybody
and making sure the culture
so
I think it would be very painful for me
to talk to my vice president and he need
to be incentivized and mobilized every
time
right this won't work if he's not if he
does not know how to incentivize or
mobilize his people it's better I don't
think he will be the vice president
they should be a good engineer good
designer but not good leader a good
leader should know
how but not by only money
most of people
incentivized or move like not because
you give them a lot of money
you give the respect
trust appreciation
and
correct heartful advice
when it comes to my meetings internal
meetings you will be shocked because we
we are not like a lot of the other
Chinese company the boss say everybody
listen take notes and go down we are
like a war room
we make decision based on whose voice is
louder right early days you know we
fight at the talk and then making sure
everybody speak up
right so this is also a way of
mobilizing and incentive there are a lot
of ways and different people have a
different weight
to send incentive rule number nine live
healthy I think life is a journey you
come to this world is to enjoy the life
to be happy and healthier so the day
when you leave the world you say I'm
happy my life I'm healthy in this life
because if you're not healthy you will
not be happy
so I believe happy and healthy are the
things the human being always looking
for and I think next to 30 years because
of the technology
the life science is going to change a
lot and people is going to live longer
but we can live longer it does not
necessarily live healthier so if you're
not healthy how can be happy if you live
longer if you're not happy while you
live there and Rule Number 10 the last
one before the bonus Clips have fun
[Music]
good
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
leaders in the world they are always
positive
they never complain others and never
complain
and they they look at the things in a
different View
like normal people
so I think
people
in my
company
they
at the beginning they don't like me
because I always think about 10 years
five years
and then
after we're working together for three
or five years they find you are right
then we got the credit
rating and as a CEO one of the jobs
where everybody's happy you have to see
the unhappy things when everybody is
unhappy you have to see the happy things
so leadership is nature but you have to
have a train and learn
and I got my leadership
sub-appecrated in Davos
I see so many you know early enter
financing how many people here know
about alipay
thank you
alipay's decision was made here
I was thinking about alipay you know but
I was not there to launch alip because
in China if you do financing without
license you will be in jail at that time
so I said I went to the banks can you
help us do the e-commerce on transaction
no no no no no no no banks would accept
it so if there will be no alipin no
financing the e-commerce would go
nowhere so I was year 2004 I was here
listen to a uh
speech by two State leaders about
leadership
and this guy's leadership is about
responsibility
you believe it but don't be the people
don't believe it
but if you think it's so critical
you should pay any price to do it
so that they changed my mind and I
called back to my team say let's launch
it
within one month if somebody has to go
to the jail I go to the gym who will be
the second one follow me if I go you
continue and you go to the jail you're
gonna continue that was they called the
leadership determination and year 2004 I
made a decision here I called back
and now today the alipay
launched and
it's so big over you know 800 million
people today using alipay globally this
is called I was born in a very uh normal
family and poor family six people sure
seven dollars a month we can only eat
one chicken a year
terrible Nixon visits to my city 1972
China USA signed a Mildred Nixon Sunday
agreement so China become Open Door my
city Hangzhou was one of the first
cities that opened to the West we got a
lot of American tourists to visit my
city what he would do is he would
befriend foreign visitors who came to
Hangzhou to walk around the West Lake
there and I learned English by being the
free guide for tour guide you know more
than the language Jack was learning
about the culture the things I learned
from books from China are so different
from the things I learned from the
American visitors so I start to think
differently because you made it this far
in a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
so it's a special celebration if you put
a hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome for 10 more amazing rules from
Jack ma check the video right there next
to me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there when I
graduate from University for three years
I try to fill in the universities so I
apply jobs for 30 times got rejected I
went for a police if you know you're not
good I went to either even the KFC